have you ever wondered about where the
Triforce was in breath of the wild we
only ever get to see simple references
to the fabled golden triangles but never
the actual artifact itself across the
Zelda universe the Triforce is featured
on tidal screens
armor sets shields and ancient art it's
no secret that the legendary artifact is
the pinnacle and most recognizable
symbol of the Legend of Zelda so why was
it not in the series's latest title
breadth of the wild not including the
Triforce seems like a deliberate choice
given its impact on the rest of the
games in the series could it be that the
Triforce wasn't present due to a greater
plotline coming into the breath of the
wild sequel that will include the golden
artifact could it be that the Triforce
will return to Hyrule hello my friends
on the Internet masculine to bandit here
and today we're gonna delve into the
Triforce its floor and its absence and
theoretical return to the land of Hyrule
along the way if you like what you're
seeing and hearing be sure to leave this
video a like so YouTube will recommend
it to other Zelda fans and subscribe to
Maskman Hannah bandit to grow our
channel thanks for watching and sticking
around and without further ado here we
go to start off with let's go over
briefly where the Triforce came from
what it is and what purpose it serves in
the world of Hyrule the Triforce was
born according to the great Deku Tree
from ocarina of time when the three
goddesses who created the world din
furore
and Nehru left their creation and
departed back to the heavens above the
Triforce was created at their point of
exit from our world
it consists of three golden triangles
each representing the essence of one
goddess their essences are power for din
wisdom for nehru and courage for furore
the balance is represented both
figuratively and literally in the
mathematical equivalence of three
congruent triangles this balance is
known as the ultimate power and legend
states that whoever touches the Triforce
will have their deepest wishes granted
however the blessing comes with an omen
in that if an individual whose heart is
imbalanced touches the relic the
Triforce will split into its separate
pieces and seek out individuals who best
represent those pieces respectively it
cannot be known for sure why the
goddesses chose to leave behind such a
glorious and horrifying temptation
the races of the world to quarrel over
but the task of defending the relic was
given to the goddess hylia her
descendants and the sheikah tribe
now that we've refreshed our minds on
the purpose of the Triforce let's talk
about where it may be in the events of
breadth of the wild since breadth of the
wild has been confirmed to take place
after all three timelines let's retrace
our steps and figure out where the
golden relic was last seen in each of
the timelines starting with the child
timeline the Triforce is last seen in
Twilight Princess although never once
mentioned by name throughout the entire
game it is clear that the Triforce is
power exists within the three
individuals chosen of the goddesses link
zelda and Ganondorf differing from
several other Zelda titles in Twilight
Princess the three start off already
wielding the pieces of the relic within
themselves as displayed on the backs of
their hands at the end of the game when
link defeats the demon king Ganondorf
the Triforce of power refuses to empower
Ganondorf leading to his death we have
no evidence that the pieces leave any of
them following the final battle so it's
very possible that the Triforce pieces
continue to follow the descendants of
the chosen three through their
bloodlines in the adult timeline the
Triforce isn't mentioned in sphere
tracks or the Phantom Hourglass it is
however a pivotal plot device in the
previous game the Wind Waker in both
similarity but also in contrast to
Twilight Princess
the game begins in the same pattern with
the Triforce divided into its three
separate triangles following the events
of Ocarina of Time the Triforce of
wisdom rests with Zelda and power rests
with Ganondorf who has returned to
Hyrule
but the Triforce of courage was
shattered into eight pieces after the
hero of time left the adult timeline to
regain his lost days as a child
meaning the hero of winds does not
possess the relics power at the end of
the game the Triforce is fully assembled
again by Ganondorf
but King daftness wishes for the land of
Hyrule to be washed away forever after
granting the wish the Triforce
disassembles and disappears into the
distance implying its return to the
Sacred Realm after its use has been
depleted
since Hyrule was then washed away after
the events of Wind Waker this definitely
explains the triforces lack of presence
in the following games in the adult
timeline finally in the fallen timeline
the Triforce is shown in its entirety
all the way up until the last game
chronologically at the end of The
Adventure of Link it is reassembled and
used to reawaken the slumbering Princess
Zelda following these events we can
assume the Triforce follows the same
behavior pattern from the Wind Waker
meaning after it acknowledges and
completes a wish it returns to the
Sacred Realm where it rests indefinitely
we know where the Triforce is before the
events of breath of the wild but to
position it properly within the game we
still need to figure out which timeline
breath of the wild stems from as
mentioned before breath of the wild
takes place after all three timelines
but is not confirmed to take place in
any of them there are two theories I
think are each believable in their own
right the first is that it takes place
in the child timeline according to this
theory we know it can't take place in
the adult timeline because of specific
landmarks being present such as the
temple of time and Lon Lon ranch from
ocarina of time or the ruins of arbiters
grounds from Twilight Princess these
landmarks exist in Hyrule the same
Hyrule that was washed away and
forgotten about at the end of the events
of the Wind Waker thus signifying that
it can't take place in the adult
timeline the Fallen timeline does show
some similarities in breadth of the wild
such as the appearance of Lionel's and
high Knox's and Link's cap having a
stripe in it but there are more
similarities with the child timeline
than there are with the falling if
breadth of the wild is a child timeline
entry this would mean that the Triforce
is still split among the chosen three
and each of them possess their shard of
the Triforce still the other theory is
actually a fourth timeline theory
sometimes called the unified timeline
this theory states that using the same
what-if mentality that spawned the
Fallen timeline what if link didn't
return to the child timeline at the end
of ocarina of time this could help
explain why the sheikah technology and
Hylian armies were so prepared for the
inevitable return of Ganon who vowed he
will eventually break out of a seal
since he still possessed the Triforce of
power after link defeated him at the end
of ocarina of time it would also help
explain the appearance of Ganondorf in
the breath of the wild sequel trailer
but that's another entire theory for
another video if we follow this timeline
theory the try
courses actually in the same state as it
would be at the end of the child
timeline split into three and resting
with the chosen individuals just like at
the ending of ocarina of time with this
being the case in either theory I think
it's safe to say that the Triforce and
breath of the wild is still resting with
link zelda and Ganondorf this would
explain how ganondorf's corpse was able
to manifest the calamity Ganon out of
malice in addition to being the vessel
of Devizes hatred the corpse still
possesses the power of the Triforce I
believe we could very well see the
return of the Triforce since Ganondorf
is now seemingly coming back to life
once he resurrects and gains
consciousness again will the Triforce
pieces shine once more will the Triforce
of power be removed from Ganondorf and
his lineage will Ganon himself be wished
away for all eternity
whatever happens if the Triforce returns
to Hyrule we can only imagine what that
will mean for breath of the wild sequel
hey guys thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this content please be
sure to LIKE subscribe and comment below
what you thought all of that will help
bring this video to other Zelda fans
just like yourself and grow the channel
I look forward to seeing you in my next
sell d'Ovidio have a great rest of your
day peace
[Music]